there are times when I feel really quite
ashamed to be a European in the last
year more than a million people arrived
in Europe in need of our help and our
response frankly has been pathetic there
are just so many contradictions we mourn
the tragic death of two-year-old Island
Coeur D and yet since then more than 200
children have subsequently drowned in
the Mediterranean we have international
treaties that recognize that refugees
are a shared responsibility and yet we
accept that trainee Lebanon hosts more
Syrians than the whole of Europe
combined with lament the existence of
human smugglers and yet we make that the
only viable route to seek asylum in
Europe we have labor shortages and yet
we exclude people who fit economic and
demographic needs from cunning to Europe
we proclaim and liberal values in
opposition to fundamentalist Islam and
yet we have repressive policies that
detain child asylum seekers that
separate children from their families
and that seize property from refugees
what are we doing how has the situation
come to this that we've adopted such an
inhumane response to a humanitarian
crisis I don't believe it's because
people don't care or at least I don't
want to believe it's because people
don't care I believe it's because our
politicians like a vision a vision for
how to adapt an international refugee
system created over 50 years ago for a
changing and globalized world and so
what I want to do is take a step back
and ask too
really fundamental questions the two
questions we all need to ask first why
is the current system not working and
second what can we do to fix it so the
modern refugee regime was created in the
aftermath the Second World War by these
guys it's basic aim is to ensure that
when a state fails or worse turns
against its own people people have
somewhere to go to live in safety and
dignity until they can go home it was
created precisely for situations like
the situation we see in Syria today
through an international convention
signed by 147 governments the 1951
Convention on the status of refugees and
an international organization UNHCR
states committed to reciprocally admit
people onto their territory who flee
conflict and persecution but today that
system is failing in theory refugees
have a right to seek asylum in practice
our immigration policies block the path
to safety in theory refugees have a
right to a pathway to integration or
return to the country they've come from
but in practice they get stuck in almost
indefinitely Bou in theory refugees are
a shared global responsibility in
practice
geography means that countries proximate
the conflict take the overwhelming
majority of the world's refugees the
system isn't broken because the rules
are wrong it's that we're not applying
them adequately to a changing world and
that's what we need to reconsider so I
want to explain to you a little bit
about how the current system works how
does the refugee regime actually work
but not from a top-down institutional
perspective rather from the perspective
of a refugee so imagine a Syrian woman
let's call her a mirror and America to
me represents many of the people I've
met in the region a mirror like around
25 percent of the world's refugees is a
woman with children and she can't go
home because
comes from this city that you see before
you Homs once beautiful and historic
city now under rubble and so a mirror
can't go back there but a mirror also
has no hope of resettlement to a third
country because that's a lottery ticket
only available to less than 1% of the
world's refugees so Amira and her family
face an almost impossible choice
they have three basic options the first
option is that a mirror can take her
family to a camp in the camp she might
get assistance but there are very few
prospects for a mirror and her family
camps rim bleach arid locations often in
the desert in the Zaatari refugee camp
in Jordan you can hear the shells across
the border in Syria at nighttime
there's restricted economic activity
education is often of poor quality and
around the world some 80 percent of
refugees who are encamped have to stay
for at least five years it's a miserable
existence and that's probably why in
reality only nine percent of Syrians
choose that option alternatively a
mirror can head to an urban area in a
neighboring country like Amman or Beirut
that's an option that about 75% of
Syrian refugees have taken but there
there's great difficulty as well
refugees in such urban areas don't
usually have the right to work they
don't usually get significant access to
assistance and so when a mirror and her
family have used up their basic savings
they're left with very little and likely
to face urban destitution so there's a
third alternative and it's one that
increasing numbers of Syrians are taking
a mirror can seek some hope for her
family by risking their lives on a
dangerous and perilous journey to
another country and it's that which
we're seeing in Europe today around the
world we present refugees with an almost
impossible choice
between three options encampment urban
destitution and dangerous journeys for
refugees that choice is the global
refugee regime today but I think it's a
false choice I think we can reconsider
that choice the reason why we limit
those options is because we think that
those are the only options that are
available to refugees and they're not
politicians frame the issue as a
zero-sum assume that if we benefit
refugees we're imposing costs on
citizens we tend to have a collective
assumption that refugees are an
inevitable cost or burden to society but
they don't have to they can contribute
so what I want to argue is there are
ways in which we can expand that choice
set and still benefit everyone else the
host states and communities our
societies and refugees themselves and I
want to suggest four ways and we can
transform the paradigm of how we think
about refugees all four ways have one
thing in common they're all ways in
which we take the opportunities of
globalization mobility and markets and
update the way we think about the
refugee issue the first one I want to
think about is the idea of enabling
environments and it starts from a very
basic recognition that refugees are
human beings like everyone else but
they're just in extraordinary
circumstances together with my
colleagues in Oxford we've embarked on a
research project in Uganda looking at
the economic lives of refugees we chose
Uganda not because it's representative
of all host countries it's not it's
exceptional unlike most host countries
around the world
what Uganda has done is give refugees
Economic Opportunity it gives them the
right to work it gives them freedom of
movement and the results of that are
extraordinary both for Refugees and the
host community in the capital city
Kampala we found that 21 percent of
refugees own a business that employs
other people and 40 percent of those
employees are Nationals of the host
country
in other words refugees are making jobs
for citizens of the host country even in
the camps
we found extraordinary examples of
vibrant flourishing and entrepreneurial
businesses for example in a settlement
called nagavalli
we found examples of Congolese refugees
running digital music exchange
businesses we found a Rwandan who runs a
business that's available to allow the
youth to play computer games on recycled
games consoles and recycle televisions
against the odds of extreme constraint
refugees are innovating and the
gentlemen you see before you is a
Congolese guy called dem ok dem ok
arrived in settlement with very little
but he wanted to be a filmmaker so with
friends and colleagues he started a
community radio station he rented a
video camera and he's now making films
he made 2 documentary films with and for
our team and he's making a successful
business out of very little it's those
kinds of examples that should guide our
response to refugees rather than seeing
refugees is inevitably dependent upon
humanitarian assistance we need to
provide them with opportunities for
human flourishing yes clothes blankets
shelter food are all important in the
emergency phase but we need to also look
beyond that we need to provide
opportunities to connectivity
electricity education the right to work
access to capital and banking all the
ways in which we take for granted that
we are plugged into the global economy
can and should apply to refugees the
second idea I want to discuss is
economic zones unfortunately not every
host country in the world take the
approach Uganda has taken most host
countries don't open up their economies
to refugees in the same way but there
are still pragmatic alternative options
that we can use last April I traveled to
Jordan with my colleague the development
economist Paul Collier and we
brainstormed an idea while we were there
with the international community and the
government an idea to bring jobs to
Syrians while supporting Jordans
national development strategy the idea
is for an economic zone one in which we
could potentially integrate the
employment of refugees alongside the
employment of Jordanian host Nationals
in just 15 minutes away from the Zaatari
refugee camp home to 83,000 refugees is
an existing economic zone called the
king Hussein bin Talal development area
the government has spent over a hundred
million dollars connecting it to the
electricity grid connecting it to the
road network but it lacked two things
access to labor and inward investment so
what if refugees were able to work there
rather than being stuck encamped able to
support their families and develop
skills through vocational training
before they go back to Syria we
recognize that that could benefit Jordan
whose development strategy requires it
to make the leap as a middle-income
country to manufacturing it could
benefit refugees but it could also
contribute to the post-conflict
reconstruction of Syria by recognizing
that we need to incubate refugees as the
best source of eventually rebuilding
Syria we published the idea in the
journal foreign affairs King Abdullah
has picked up on the idea it was
announced at the London Syria conference
two weeks ago and the pilot will begin
in the summer
the third idea that I want to put to you
it's preference matching between States
and refugees to lead to the kinds of
happy outcomes you see here in the
selfie featuring Angela Merkel and a
Syrian refugee what we rarely do is ask
refugees what they want where they want
to go but I'd argue we can do that and
still make everyone better off The
Economist Alvin Roth has developed the
idea of matching markets ways in which
the preference ranking of the parties
shapes an eventual match my colleagues
will Joan's Analects title Boeing have
explored ways in which this idea could
be applied to refugees to ask refugees
to rank their preferred destinations but
also allow states to rank the types of
refugees they want on skills criteria or
language criteria and allow those to
match now of course you need to build in
quotas on things like diversity and
vulnerability but it's a way of
increasing the possibilities of matching
the matching idea has been successfully
used to match for instance students with
university places to match kidney donors
with patients and it underlies the kind
of algorithm exists on dating websites
so why not apply that to give refugees
greater choice it could also be used at
the national level where one of the
great challenges we face is to persuade
local communities to accept refugees and
at the moment in my country for instance
we often send engineers to rural areas
and farmers to the cities which makes no
sense at all so matching markets offer a
potential way to bring those preferences
together and listening to the needs and
demand of the populations that host and
the refugees themselves the fourth idea
I want to put to you is of humanitarian
basis much of the tragedy in chaos we've
seen in Europe was entirely avoidable it
stems from a fundamental contradiction
in Europe's asylum policy which is the
following that in order to seek asylum
in Europe you have to arrive
spontaneously by embarking on those
dangerous journeys that I described but
why should those journeys be necessary
era of the budget airline and modern
consular capabilities they completely
unnecessary journeys and last year they
led to the deaths of over 3,000 people
on Europe's borders and within European
territory
if refugees were simply allowed to
travel directly and seek asylum in
Europe we would avoid that and there's a
way of doing that through something
called a humanitarian visa that allows
people to collect a visa at an embassy
or a consulate in a neighboring country
and then simply pay their own way
through a ferry or a flight to Europe it
costs around a thousand euros to take a
smuggler from Turkey to the Greek
islands it costs 200 euros to take a
budget airline from Bodrum to Frankfurt
if we allowed Refugees to do that it
would have major advantages it would
save lives it would undercut the entire
market for smugglers and it would remove
the chaos we see from Europe's front
line in areas like the Greek islands
it's politics that prevents us doing
that rather than a rational solution and
this is an idea that has been applied
Brazil has adopted a pioneering approach
where over 2,000 Syrians have been able
to get humanitarian visas enter Brazil
and claim refugee status on arrival in
Brazil and in that scheme every Syrian
who's gone through it has received
refugee status and been recognized as a
genuine refugee there's a historical
precedent for it as well between 1922
and 1942 these Nansen passports we used
a travel document to allow 450,000
Assyrians
Turks and Chechens to travel across
Europe and claim refugee status
elsewhere in Europe and the Nansen
international refugee office received
the Nobel Peace Prize in recognition of
this being a viable strategy so all four
of these ideas that I presented you a
ways in which we can expand a mirror's
choice set their ways in which we can
have greater choice for refugees beyond
those basic impossible three options I
explained to you and still leave other
better off in conclusion we really need
a new vision a vision that enlarges the
choices of refugees but recognizes that
they don't have to be a burden there's
nothing inevitable about refugees being
a cost yes they are a humanitarian
responsibility but they're human beings
with skills talents aspirations with the
ability to make contributions if we let
them in the new world migration is not
going to go away what we've seen in
Europe will be with us for many years
people will continue to travel they'll
continue to be displaced and we need to
find rational realistic ways of managing
this not based on the old logics of
humanitarian assistance not based on
logics of charity but building on the
opportunities offered by globalization
markets and mobility I'd urge you all to
wake up and urge our politicians to wake
up to this challenge thank you very much